finally after a few years of development
it looks like the sci-fi classic is
going to get a remake and considering
today's cultural and political climate I
think there are some people that can
assume this is going to be a load of
woke rubbish but I'm very excited about
the possibility welcome to Sid Trek your
Sci-Fi TV and movie
[Music]
channel
Alien Nation starring James khah and
Mandy Patinkin was a movie in 1988 that
as far as I'm concerned became an
immediate classic syes here's your new
partner my true name
is it was obviously a Sci-Fi cult
classic that then spawned a TV series
starring Gary Graham and Eric peero to
be honest actors that did the parts
beautifully in their own right for a TV
series that was just taken away from us
after 22 Episodes even though it did
then spawn a couple of TV movies Comics
novels The Works Alien Nation is still a
brilliant movie it holds up today if you
can go and get a copy I strongly suggest
you do the TV series was just as good
and a remake reboot reimagining whatever
has been in development for quite some
time Jeff Nichols was supposed to write
and direct back in 2018 he actually had
a deal in place he was going to have
hundred million dollars to spend on this
it would have been epic but it fell
through something that he since said was
Soul destroying Jeff Nichols is actually
a guy that you might know from a recent
movie called Midnight Special A Very
spielbergian typee of movie to its feel
it really is an excellent sci-fi movie
this guy knows how to make this kind of
film for me alienation has to be dark
gritty realistic the whole tone of the
movie is based around the fact that if
this actually happened how would people
react how would the aliens react and I
think Jeff Nichols really does get that
so 2018 this is going to happen but it
didn't but Jeff didn't give up they
would then reported this was going to be
a 10 episode season 4
Disney plus because this is actually
owned by Fox and Disney plus own Fox
obviously but that also didn't happen
and to be honest I don't think it's
going to happen now simply because
Disney are now going to be very very
cautious about what they actually spend
money on over the next five years they
owe quite a lot they need to get their
costs down and my understanding talking
to people in the industry is that the
plan is for them to go back to basics
over the next few few years so don't
expect anything even remotely risky from
Disney for a while I say that though but
alienation doesn't actually have to be
particularly risky it doesn't really
have to be an expensive Sci-Fi show
comparatively it wouldn't be much more
expensive than any other sort of cop
show other than half the cast are going
to be wearing sort of a headpiece that
makes them look like an alien other than
that it's just a downto earth cop show
so compared to Star Trek and stuff
doesn't have to be that expensive but
Disney won't be going that way my
sources are telling me though that 20th
century pictures are going to be given
permission to push forwards with this as
a TV movie straight to Hulu now think
prey because that's basically the line
they're going to be going with this it's
bringing back a big franchise but
they're going to do it in a very certain
way very gritty very realistic very
stripped back there will not be loads of
special effects Alien Nation doesn't
need it anyway and it will be a sci-fi
movie for adults this will not be a Kids
film and it shouldn't be anyway there's
loads of drug use Etc in it and it will
be very much again along the lines of
the same budget Etc as prey so we'll be
talking around a budget of 50 million
for this type of project that's actually
a very healthy budget and would allow
them to really do something I think
quite exciting
but why do I think that it deserves a
remake why do I think it should come
back because as I've said the original
movie in series actually do stand up
well a lot of the issues that the film
is about is about inequality and I would
say in Europe and in America at the
moment inequality has become a real
problem again racism sexism all of these
things are massive issues we struggle
with them every day the left is
attacking the right and the right is
attacking the left and most of us that
are stuck in the middle really don't
know which side to go films like
alienation and to be honest sci-fi in
general when it's done well tackles
these issues properly and alienation
through you know a very subtle not so
subtle metaphor really can help us to
think about things like racism
inequality within gender inequality
within sexuality etc etc in a very non
inyou face non preachy kind of way the
alienation movie and then the following
series was very dark it was done
realistically something again I think
this director and writer can do it was
done with real Soul it didn't have to
tell you that this was wrong it showed
you the movie points out again because
we're looking at it through the eyes of
this alien species it shows us how
ridiculous a lot of the rituals and a
lot of the things that we on a daily
basis do and how idiotic it is for us to
criticize everything that's different to
us yes when this film comes out on Hulu
a lot of people are going to shout woke
at it and to be honest if Jeff Nichols
allows any agenda to overtake what is
actually a relatively simple and clever
story then yeah it's going to be a load
of rubbish but at its C or the
alienation movie isn't about race it
isn't really about bigotry it's about
friendship it's a cop buddy movie it's
an action movie it's about standing up
for what is right yes it's about looking
past differences and yes it's about
looking for the good in people and yes
okay it's a strong metaphor for racism
bigotry and how ridiculous that is but
if they get the core of this right and
action cop buddy
movie then this is a film I can't wait
to see but guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think is Alien
Nation a movie that deserves the Remake
do we want a series as well do we really
mind either way I actually think a movie
this fits a movie really good so I'd be
really happy with it but I'd love to
know what you think so get into the
comments also if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos Premiere first and you even get a
free gift after three months don't
forget as well there is
s.co which is our dedicated website and
they have articles from most of our
videos that really try to add a little
bit more meat on the bones for you to
digest as always please stay safe and
I'll catch you next
time